three black guys here i don't know if
you guys have had it but i've had it
right when you've been out with like
white guys
and
they get a little bit drinking them and
then the jokes turn towards your piece
have you had that oh bears it's normal
like that's something that i don't get
like when it comes to like the
interracial like just the
the race thing like i don't it's like
why is my business on like why are we
talking about my question do you do you
mean you don't get or you don't get
those comments
no i get comments he doesn't understand
i don't understand why like i'm just
wondering when it comes to like i just
think that's a weird thing to bring up
no no because now the reason why is i
i'll kind of like um
level it out because the fetish is eight
who talk about fetishization before
right of like black and white and i'm
wondering do
is there a stigma with
black men and that
you know i mean and it's not just within
white women but it's also within white
men i don't know
does that make sense yeah again i'm not
like upset at that stigma if that makes
sense yeah you know exactly
but i think that's not a big thing i
think that's more historical though
because even like if you look at romans
like they saw this is barbaric and over
time that's been
changed and so like
it's it's now it's a thing of like
people want that
so maybe that's what they speak about
because it's a bit of a banter a way to
make themselves feel a bit more
because there's a lot of positive racism
i remember
obviously this is slightly tangible to
like growing up when i was younger i
used to i used to go to academy trials
and then i remember one time i didn't
get the ball and like run past someone
and the coach was just like you're the
quickest person here like why didn't you
show them your pace i'm thinking you've
never seen me run in your life
you've just seen my cullen you've
assumed
so just like when it comes to the
positive racism i think we're less
likely i know as mundane we're less
likely to be like
to make it problem um positive racism i
don't think we should call it that well
it's too hot it's so it's to my benefit
in the fact
when i call it positive racism it's the
fact of
you might now pick me in your academy
because you think i'm quick which is to
my benefit but the whole reason why
you're picking me
is actually racist but it positively
benefits me no i just feel like that's
expectations
and having those expectations
generalized across a race just because
of how you look mm-hmm so i don't think
that but that can can that work in your
favor though i'm saying it positively
benefits favor but i don't think
positive is the right word well
something works in your favor it's
positive it's the same as i think it's
just the two can't go together because
racism is never positive so you can't
just say it's positive
but in that instance it is over here in
that instance it is positive because
he's benefited from the fact that
somebody was racist has discriminated
again against him for his color
but what is it because he could because
they expected him to run fast because
i'm black here because he's black it's
not because they expected him to run
fast it's because the reason why that
happened was purely because he's black i
think there's just there's just some
notions that we shouldn't talk about
language but well there's some issues
when you talk about language and
um things like racism if you find the
right word
i think then you can like let us know
but i've always i think i think
everyone's waiting on like
new words
yeah i i know we all hear what we're
saying and we all feel what we're saying
because if you root back to racism it's
we've never seen it in a positive light
but now nowadays um it's just
stereotypes
um some people think it's positive but
yeah but i think i think we're getting
lost on sabbath